Speaker 1: Florida Governor Ron DeSantis war with
Disney World has now gone up yet another notch,
with DeSantis threatening to build a
state prison right next to Disney World,
which is hard to even say with a straight face
that this guy is so petty and so vindictive. But
he is. Let me remind you the back story here.
Disney faced internal pressure some time ago
to come out and criticize what is known as the
don't say gay bill in Florida. And the don't say
gay bill in Florida is this bill signed into law
which places restrictions on what can be taught in
Florida classrooms about gender identity and about
sexual orientation as applied to kindergarten
through third grade. There was internal pressure
at Disney for them to come out and say, We are
against this law. So Disney did that, and DeSantis
and Florida Republicans flipped out. They said
that Disney is going woke and they subsequently
decided to punish Disney, including by taking
control of that district, which basically operated
as a private municipal government by Disney. And
it contained Walt Disney World and some other
parks. And this has continued to grow and grow and
grow. This is not really a battle I think DeSantis
can win, because even though I hate theme parks,
I'm aware that tons of people love them and
tons of people love Disney and the movies,
and Disney is generally very well-liked. And
so this is a risky thing for DeSantis to do.
In addition now to saying that he is going to
start sending inspectors to look at the rides
at Walt Disney World, he now threw out the idea
during an event yesterday that maybe he will build
a prison next to Disneyworld, take that district.
Speaker 3: You know, one of the things they tried
to do was was put restrictive covenants on the
land that the district owns. So if you look at
this whole special district, Walt Disney
Corporation obviously owns a lot of it,
but the district owns other land. You know, I
frankly, I wasn't even thinking about that plan.
This was not something that was really important
one way or another. We just wanted to live under
the same rules, pay the debt, pay the taxes,
all that stuff. Oh, but come to think of it now,
people are like, well, what should we do with this
land? And so, you know, it's like, okay, kids,
I mean, people have said, you know, maybe maybe
have another maybe create a state park, maybe try
to do more amusement parks. Someone even said,
like, maybe you need another state prison. Who
knows? I mean, I just think that the possibilities
are endless. And so that is now going to be
analyzed to see what would make the most sense.
Speaker 1: Okay. So he's it's not we're having
fun. He's joking. The crowd's laughing.
It's all super, super interesting.
This should actually be chilling. This shouldn't
send a tingle down your leg the way Chris MATTHEWS
once said. This should really send a chill down
your spine, because what we are talking about
here is a guy who claims to have an ideology of
not interfering with businesses, being against
regulation, welcoming the tax revenue that comes
from businesses. I mean, what we're talking about,
like the state's largest tourist attraction by far
and antagonizing them is certainly an interesting
economic and political decision. But this is yet
another example. It's another data point of how
they immediately and with total reckless abandon,
will get away from their stated principles if it's
not convenient or if they're upset or if they
want revenge or if they want to ruin somebody's
day because they don't like politically the
things that are going on. He is openly using his
political power. He has already done it and he is
threatening to do more of it against his perceived
enemies, including corporate enemies. This is
extraordinarily dangerous stuff. And despite
all the claims that it's the Democrats that want
to overregulate and hurt business and all these
different things. I've never seen anything like
this openly and overtly and brazenly. So is he
literally going to propose building a state prison
right next to Walt Disney World? I don't know.
Maybe. Maybe not. It's not totally clear. But this
is exactly the stuff that we've been talking about
when we say these are not only hypocrites, but
they are dangerously, dangerously hypocritical.
And remember, it's all over. Don't say gay. That's
how this all started. Disney said, hey, we don't
like this. Everybody's welcome here. By the way,
Walt Disney World. I've never again. I've been to
Disney once when I was like 18. I guess they're
known for all sorts of corporate events where
you can I don't know if the park is closed down
or what, but they do everything from corporate
events to Pride Day to Gay Weekend or whatever
else the case may be. It's also profitable
for Disney. Whatever you assess to be Disney's
political view, like, does Disney have a political
view? Is Disney pro-gay? I don't know. But they
certainly know that their bread is buttered by
all sorts of different people, including LGBT
groups and tourists and travelers and whatever
else the case may be. So this is as much out
of self-preservation as it is about whatever
Disney thinks is right and fair and good. I don't
know that the Santas can actually win this one,
but it's certainly clear he's willing to try just
about anything in order to take a shot at that.